التدافع الامريكي الصيني يخيم على طروحات
وزراء الدفاع والقاده العسكريين في حوار
شانجريلا في سنغافوره في الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها يتحدثون عن استراتيجيه امنيه
ودفاعيه لهم لمواجهه ما يرونه مدا صينيه
في منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ مع
ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مع بيجين
تؤمن الولايات المتحده باهميه التواصل مع
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه لا سيما بين
قياداتنا العسكريه والدفاعيه بالنسبه
للقاده العسكريين فان الوقت المناسب
للتحدث هو في اي وقت والوقت المناسب
للتحدث هو الان
[موسيقى]
واشنطن وحلفائها يسعون الى تسريع بناء
تحالفات امنيه وعسكريه في شرق اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ
وشهدت المياه الاسيويه تدريبات ومناورات
امريكيه بوتيره اوسعه مع حلفائه وشركاء
اسيويين وهو ما تراه الصين تصعيده
تحتاج الولايات المتحده الى تغيير افعالها
الخاطئه في تعاملها مع الاخرين يقولون
دعونا نتحاور لكن ما الذي سنتحدث عنه
عندما يتعلق الامر بالحوار عليك ان تهتم
بمصالح الطرف الاخر لذلك نقول دائما ان
هذا لا ينفصل عن الامن اما وزراء دفاع دول
اسيان فيتطلعون الى تحديث قدراتهم
العسكريه نظرا للتوتر المتزايد في المنطقه
جراء التباين الاستراتيجي بين الولايات
المتحده والصين
لكن بعض عواصم اسيان تريد نزع فتيل الازمه
وليس حربا بارده ولا حقيقيه قرب مياهيه
لدي قناعه بان قاده كل من الصين والولايات
المتحده والغرب سيسعون لحل هذا الصراع من
خلال التسويه والتعاون والروح الانسانيه
ما يؤدي الى حل سلمي لخلافاتهم
اندونيسيا ودول اخرى في المنطقه تتطلع الى
ان يتحلى قاده الدول العظمى بالحكمه بما
يشيع التفاؤل عالميه
يزداد المشهد توترا في شرق اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ فالامريكيون يرون مدا صينيا عسكريا
واقتصاديا والصينيون مرتابون من عوده
الحضور الامريكي وتشكيل واشنطن تحالفات
جديده مع دول المنطقه بينما تتطلع دول
جنوب شرق اسيا الى تجنيب المنطقه اي صراع
محتمل صحيح جاسم الجزيره
سنغافوره